[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Thank you all for being
here tonight this afternoon.
And let me first say
that I'm so incredibly
thankful to the Radcliffe
Institute for this time
and this space to do my work,
to work on this project,
to nurture a new project,
and for the opportunity to be
and work with such a
phenomenal group of people.
I really am thankful
for that opportunity.
At the 2016 Super
Bowl, Beyonce performed
her new single,
"Formation," with a league
of women with afros dressed in
black and berets behind her,
an obvious homage to
the Black Panther Party,
which celebrates its 50th
anniversary this year.
Beyonce's Super Bowl
performance reflects
a renewed popular interest
in the Black Power movement.
The controversial performance
resulted in many critiques,
ranging all the
way from a critique
of her use of the
Black Power movement's
legacy for her own
fame and fortune
to concerns that she brought
the image of a racist group
to America's sport.
Regardless of one's
position on the "queen bee,"
in this historical moment where
black people must proclaim
the value of their lives
against state violence
and the prison industrial
complex is being analyzed
and challenged by black
academics and activists,
it is most certainly
a fitting time
to revisit a movement that was
centrally concerned with police
brutality and with
mass incarceration.
It becomes even clearer why
it's essential to look again
at Black Power when we
remember the movement
that black students are
waging against campus
racism across the country.
As the movement that
inspired students and faculty
to demand black studies programs
and black student unions
and demand not just access,
but space in our universities,
it's no surprise that
Black Power, again,
is taking a prominent role
in the popular imaginary.
Perhaps most importantly,
though, the Black Power
movement occurred on the
cusp of a new form of racism,
a form of racism that continues
to exist and shape shift
against the backdrop of
alleged legal equality.
This period in the development
of a post-civil rights
racial ideology, one that's
strikingly similar to what
we have today, offers an
important comparative landscape
for understanding
black movements today
and for understanding white
resistance to those movements.
Sorry to take
Beyonce away from--
[LAUGHTER]
So what I want to do today
is to talk to you a bit
about my work on the
Black Power movement.
So my research grew out of a
curiosity about whether and how
movements shape that wide
range of institutions
that exist between
the level of the state
and the level of
the family-- things
like schools,
workplaces, churches,
voluntary associations,
and so forth, the places
where our day-to-day
lives take place.
And I'm particularly interested
in how black people in the US,
embedded in white-dominated
educational institutions
and workplaces, bring
the ideas, strategies,
and tactics of black
liberation movements with them.
In this vein, my
work has primarily
been concerned with
how Black Power made
an impact on institutions.
In my first book, I
argue that the rise
of black professional
associations
in the late 1960s and early
'70s is a direct outcome
of Black Power.
And I detail that process in
the profession of social work.
My second book that I'm
working on here at Radcliffe
is about a group of attorneys
who organized themselves
to be the legal wing of the
revolution during the Black
Power era.
I have a second line
of research that
looks at race-based policy
in higher education.
I've been interested in how
colleges and universities use,
or fail to use, policy in
the service of racial equity
and, in particular, in the
role of campus activism
in shaping that process.
So in some ways, my
work is a departure
from the image of the
Black Power movement
that Beyonce channeled
at the Super Bowl
to be sure the Black Power
movement has been portrayed
as the quintessential bad
boy of black movement making.
All afros, black leather, and
guns-- the Black Power movement
lives in the popular imaginary
as a deviant wild child
of black social movements.
As a new student
of the movement,
I was also fascinated
with this image,
the image of the
young radical emerging
from the disappointments of
the Civil Rights movement
with a new attitude, a
new swagger, if you will,
ready to take on white racism
by any means necessary.
There is certainly an affinity
between my generation,
the hip-hop generation, and
the Black Power generation
that drove my initial
interest in the movement.
So I used to just
have pictures here.
But then when I learned
how to loop Beyonce,
I was like, why wouldn't
I loop them, too?
So anyway-- [LAUGHS] --now
you get Public Enemy, as well.
So much of hip-hop culture in
the late 1980s and early 1990s
reflects an admiration
of the Black Power
figures who were willing to
risk everything to say enough
is enough.
So if you know Hip-Hop,
you can think back
to KRS-One or Public Enemy,
who you see projected here,
and the way that their music
and their visual presence
reflected a Black Power ethic.
A problem, though, with this
image and with this fascination
is that it's really limited
the way that we remember
the movement and, certainly,
how we think about the impact
that it's had on US society.
We look at the Black Panther
Party and groups like them
and say, well,
they certainly had
an impact on black
culture-- things
like popularizing,
re-popularizing the afro,
the idea that black is
beautiful, new forms of music,
et cetera-- but not
much beyond that.
But there is more to
the movement than this.
There's also a
strain of Black Power
that was centrally concerned
with institution building.
The idea of building
independent black institutions
is an old one in black America.
And the Black Power movement
was centrally concerned with it.
So if this were
1969 or 1970 and we
were in a
movement-related meeting
and I asked you,
what time is it,
in the call-and-response
tradition
of the black
community, the answer
is, it's nation time, meaning
that the movement called
for black people to build
the kinds of structures
and institutions
that go into building
a nation-- economic
stability, education, faith,
family-- in a way that
would benefit black people.
So my first book
project, again, looks
at the rise of black
professional associations
as this sort of outcome of
the Black Power movement.
And I see that development as
the same sort of phenomenon
as the rise of black studies
programs, black student unions,
black museums, independent
black educational institutions,
and so forth.
These are the sorts
of outcomes that
resulted from Black Power's
push to both carve out
space in existing
institutions and build
new independent institutions.
And this strain of the
movement is less understood.
So what I want to
do moving forward
is talk just a little bit
about how social science is
particularly guilty
of underestimating
the impact of
Black Power, how we
can contribute to fixing
that by rethinking
race-based movements,
in particular.
And then I want to use
some data from the book
to talk about how
Black Power shaped
the rise of black professional
associational life
before giving you just a little
bit about my work in progress.
So sociology has been
particularly dismissive
of Black Power.
It's really been
treated as an aside
to Civil Rights in that it
had been seen as really only
important in as much as it
affected the Civil Rights
movement, that it
lent credibility
to the more moderate
demands of Civil Rights.
With very few exceptions,
the sociological literature
on social movements has
been guilty of ignoring
the lasting impacts
of the movement,
or worse-- lumping Black
Power activists together
as sort of a ragtag group
of unorganized thugs.
In fact, Doug McAdam cites Peter
Goldman with no qualification
when he calls the Black
Power movement a, quote,
"ghetto-bred generation with
reputations no larger than
a single city or a neighborhood
or even a particular block."
And as it turns out,
that's just not true.
This is primarily
because sociologists
have made many studies
of race-based movements
without paying
attention to race.
And as a result,
sociologists have mostly
thought about movement
impacts as changes
at the level of the state.
So what matters about
the Civil Rights movement
is that there was legislation
that came as a result of it.
But what race scholars know is
that the social relations that
create, maintain, and
reproduce racial inequality
are embedded throughout society.
In other words, racial
meanings and racism
are not only outcomes of
state-initiated processes,
nor are they simply
ideas that people can
choose to ascribe to or not.
Rather, racial
meanings and racism
are developed and expressed in
and through the organizations
and institutions in
which we all interact.
So when we understand that power
is dispersed throughout society
and that race and racism
shape all social institutions,
we necessarily have to look at
how race-based movements impact
these other institutions.
So in the book, I
developed this idea
of civil institutionalization
to get at this idea
that movements get imported
into the institutions
of civil society.
And this is certainly the
case with Black Power.
So the roots of the
Black Power movement
began much earlier than the
1966 date that most of us
attribute to it.
US black radicalism certainly
didn't begin in 1966,
nor did the idea of
black nationalism
or a movement for black
social, political,
and economic power begin then.
Still, the popular narrative
is one in which black radicals
emerged on the scene near the
end of what Peniel Joseph calls
the "heroic period" of
the Civil Rights Movement.
The reality is that there
have always been at least two
connected, and
sometimes opposing,
black political
cultures-- one that sees
assimilation or integration
into the white mainstream
as an appropriate goal
for African-Americans
and another that
promotes the rejection
of white institutions,
norms, and values.
So really, as the Civil
Rights Movement gave way
to Black Power in the
mid-1960s, this second,
more radical political
culture came into dominance.
And following on the heels of
the Watts rebellion of 1965,
Black Power gave
voice to a generation,
a generation of black
people who wanted more--
more than the Civil Rights
Movement was asking for
and certainly more than
the establishment was
willing to give.
But more than this,
Black Power rejected
the peaceful, nonviolent
approach of the Civil Rights
Movement, claiming, instead,
that black liberation was
an immediate emergency
matter of survival.
The Black Power
movement threw off
the decorum of someone
like King and chose
to speak plainly, forcefully,
and without regard
for white feelings.
So just briefly, Black Power
as a movement took many forms
and was made up of a
wide range of individuals
and organizations.
But at the core, the
Black Power movement
marked a move away from
the goals of integration
that were central
to Civil Rights
and toward a desire for
radical social change,
a focus on self-help
and self-defense
in the black community
and a rejection
of white aesthetic
cultural norms and values.
Self-definition,
self-determination,
and black pride were
central to Black Power.
In concrete struggles
over community control
over organizations
within black communities,
struggles around
police brutality,
welfare reform all occurred
under the umbrella of Black
Power.
So while the images I
showed earlier of groups
like the Black
Panther Party dominate
how we think about the movement,
there was more to the movement
than those images that
dominated news reports and FBI
surveillance reports.
There was a strain
of the movement
that was aimed at dismantling
institutionalized racism.
Stokely Carmichael-- later Kwame
Toure-- and Charles Hamilton
wrote a book called Black Power.
And in it, they explicated one
of the first social science
theories of
institutionalized racism--
the idea that racial meanings
and racial inequality
become embedded in
institutions, they
become embedded
institutional practices,
and are not necessarily
dependent on racist attitudes.
The book also makes the
case that black people
need a twofold strategy--
one, to have black community
representatives within
existing institutions
to represent black
interests, and, two,
to build independent
black institutions.
So this notion that black
people need to close ranks
was certainly not new.
But the call in Black
Power, the book,
really reflects
and sets an agenda
for this institution-building
element of the movement
and was manifested in all
sorts of organizations
and within American politics.
So as the idea of Black
Power was popularized,
established black
leaders attempted
to define it
politically, leading
to a series of Black
Power conferences.
The most well-known
Black Power conference
was held between July
20th and July 23rd of 1967
in the wake of one of the
bloodiest black rebellions
in US history.
Lasting from July
11th until July 17th,
the Newark rebellion had
left over 20 people dead
and at least 1,000 injured.
So as you can imagine,
there was some conflict
over the timing
of the conference.
Still, over 1,000 delegates
and representatives
from 286 organizations attended
this first national Black Power
conference.
The conference document opens
with this basis for action--
"Whereas, the Black people
stand at the crossroads
of either an expanding
revolution or ruthless
extermination, it
is incumbent upon us
to set our house in order.
And whereas Black
people have consistently
expended too much energy
and resources reflecting
to white definitions,
it is imperative
that organizational and
technical competence develop
to initiate and enact new
insights, new definitions,
and new programs."
The Black Power conferences
built a power base
and an organizational
vehicle for the development
of black political conventions
and a stronger black presence
in mainstream politics.
And this idea of black
faces in higher places,
or what I'm calling
the black radical march
through the institutions,
was a central theme.
So the impact of the
Black Power movement
on black participation in
mainstream electoral politics
is clear.
From the election
of black mayors
to the development of the
Congressional Black Caucus,
Black Power's theme of building
political and institutional
power shaped African-American
participation
in the US political mainstream.
What you see up here is Ebony
Magazine's progress report.
Every January, they published
a progress report for the year
before.
And the story of
the year for 1967
was the election of black mayors
in cities across the United
States.
But the nation-building strain
of the Black Power movement
was not only played out
in the political arena.
From the rise of
black studies programs
and the development of
black student unions
the creation of independent
black educational institutions
black theaters and black
museums African-Americans
used the fuel of the
Black Power movement
to develop independent
black institutions
throughout civil society.
And this phenomenon
is important not only
because it changed the
organizational structure
of civil society,
but also because it
created important shifts
in racial practices
in organizations and
contributed to the greater
incorporation of the
black middle class
into white institutions.
But in the literature
on the movement,
very little is known
about this process.
And let me just say here that
this importation of Black
Power into mainstream
organizations
certainly contributed
to a watering
down of Black
Power in such a way
that its transformatory
potential would be co-opted
into something that looks
more like today's diversity
initiatives than what it looked
like at its most revolutionary.
Still, this process of
translating and incorporating
tenets of the Black
Power movement
into major institutions
in US society
created important shifts that
are important to understand.
So in the 1960s, large
cohorts of African-Americans
entered several academic and
professional disciplines.
Their numbers were
unprecedented.
And they were the immediate
products of the Civil Rights
and Black Power movements.
And these professionals
were often not satisfied
with just integrating their
professions with their bodies
with just demographic
integration.
On the contrary, they came to
their professions with a desire
to make changes on behalf
of the black community.
They wanted to use
the professions
as a tool for black liberation,
indeed for Black Power.
But they encountered
professional structures
that had been operating
on a logic of exclusion,
many of which had been formed
for the purpose of exclusion
and, as such, were resistant to
change and often unprepared for
and unwelcoming of integration,
not to mention Black Power.
So across the country, groups
of black professionals,
empowered by the legal and
social gains of the Civil
Rights Movement and inspired
and emboldened by Black Power,
sought to implement the
gains of the movement
into their professions.
And this process was widespread.
There's no expectation for
you to read all of this.
I just put this list here
so you can see magnitude.
These are just foundings of
professional associations.
And the national
professional associations
of black psychologists,
journalists, sociologists,
economists, social
workers, firefighters,
political scientists,
accountants, and librarians,
just to name a few, were all
formed between 1968 and 1976.
And this is just
simple counts-- a chart
to show you that the founding of
black professional associations
maps onto what we think
about as a Black Power era.
And all these organizations
had as their explicit goals
to both change their
profession for the good
of black professionals
within them,
but also to change their
profession's relationship
and practice with
the black community.
These organizations were not
the first black professional
associations.
But they were created under
very different circumstances
than their predecessors.
The National Medical
Association and the National Bar
Association, for example,
were not necessarily formed
because they wanted a
racially-oriented organization,
as is evidenced by the
national parallel names
to their American counterparts.
They were formed because
African-Americans were excluded
from the American counterparts.
In contrast, the Black Power era
black professional associations
were born out of unprecedented
access to white ones.
The increased access to
white-dominated professions
and professional
associations coincided
with the dominance of
Black Power politics
in a way that led black
professionals to bring
the movement with them.
The Black Power influence on
these organizations is clear.
They all saw the move
away from integration
as the primary goal
of black action
within the professions--
they already
had that-- in favor of
seeking self-determination
for black professionals
and black communities.
The founders of
these organizations
worked in the Black
Power tradition
of challenging white racism.
They reflected Black
Power's change in tenor
from the Civil Rights
Movement, which
no longer saw the removal
of barriers as enough.
They didn't shy away from
demanding black representation
within their professions
or from labeling
longstanding professional
practices as racist.
If you look at
these organizations,
many of them, to this day, have
red, black, and green logos,
the colors of black nationalism.
Many were founded with
10 or 12-point platforms,
reflecting the tactic
of the Black Panther
Party and other Black
Power organizations.
Another commonality is that
these organizations were not
founded quietly.
They took over meetings.
They issued manifestos.
They made demands.
They insisted.
These organizations
were formed in
and served as the vehicle for
protest within the professions.
The Association of Black
Psychologists, for example,
was formed in September of 1968.
They issued a series of demands
for the American Psychological
Association-- the APA.
And the demands clearly
reflect a Black Power ethic.
For one, they demanded
that, "the APA
bring to bear its full
resources on finding solutions
to the problem of
racism and poverty
and recognize that a significant
part of research emphasis
must be shifted away from
the total preoccupation
with the ghetto as
a source of problems
to consideration of the
forces within the larger
white community that contribute
so heavily to the maintenance
of the status quo."
And when the
newly-formed organization
disrupted the annual
meetings of the APA in 1969,
they argued that
the black community
had served as a research
colony for social scientists.
Robert Green argued that-- this
is a quote-- "Psychologists
and sociologists go
into the black community
and do research, but
refuse to specify and push
major programs of improvement
for the black community."
He went on to say, "Do not
use us for research efforts
any longer.
Help us, instead, to mitigate
the effects of white racism."
Black librarians organized the
Black Caucus of the American
Library Association in 1969.
The statement of concern that
they presented to the American
Library Association--
the ALA-- in 1970
also reflected this
Black Power ethic.
In their brief
statement, they assert,
"Black librarians are
especially concerned
about the effects of
institutional racism,
poverty, the continued lack
of educational, employment,
and promotional
opportunities for blacks
and other minorities."
And in a condemnation
of the discipline,
they referenced the 1968
report of the National Advisory
Commission on Civil Disorders,
or the Kerner Commission
report, arguing that, although
these socioeconomic ills have
been condemned by the Kerner
Commission, the Commission
on Violence, and
many other studies,
the library profession has
been slow in responding
to these problems.
And you might be
wondering, what do
they expect the library
profession to do, right?
And so I'm going to
give you an example.
And I think it's a
really clear example
of this idea of translating
the goals of the movement
into their professional lives.
So the first official resolution
they pushed through the ALA
Council was in response
to library practices
in segregated schools.
So the founders of
the Black Caucus
were troubled by the
number of private schools
that were founded
in the United States
in order to avoid integration.
These schools were the
result of white flight
after the Civil Rights Movement.
And many of the
new white schools
couldn't afford
their own libraries.
And so they asked local
libraries to support them.
Black Caucus founders saw
this as a prime opportunity
to hold their profession
accountable for the gains
of the movement for
supporting school integration
and asked them to refuse to
support these white flight
schools.
After a heated debate,
the Black Caucus
was successful in passing the
following resolution-- "That
the libraries or
librarians who do,
in fact, through their
services or materials,
support any such racist
institution be censured
by the American
Library Association
and that the ALA staff give
the widest possible publicity
to this action."
So this Black Caucus
resolution is a prime example
of how Black Power era
professionals creatively
translated the goals
and ethic of Black Power
into their
disciplinary contexts.
So these are just two examples
of how Black Power era
professionals brought the ideas
and strategies of the movement
into their professions
and mounted a challenge
against institutional racism.
But I also find that black
professional associations
of the era served four
important purposes
within their professions.
First, they did identity work.
So I saw a lot of this sort
of talking and writing around,
what does it mean to be really
black and a professional?
And by "really black," meaning
committed to black liberation,
committed to the movement, and
a professional at the same time.
Secondly, that they
served as a protest wing--
so black professional
associations were often
and continue to be more
willing to engage in activist
social justice activities
than are their mainstream
counterparts.
The third is a focus on
professional equality--
so challenging practices
that unfairly benefited
their white colleagues
in promotion or in being
placed on committees,
things like that.
And the last thing I
talk about is monitors,
so that they sort of served
as the black conscience
within the profession.
So if there were
practices of a profession
that they thought harmed
the black community, APA,
for example-- the Association
of Black Psychologists--
they called for a moratorium on
IQ testing of black children,
because IQ tests
were unfairly biased
against black kids in schools.
So this was one of
these sort of being
a monitor about the
profession's practices.
In short, black professionals
during the Black Power era
turned the black power
gaze onto their work lives
to challenge racism
within their professions.
Black people in the US
shaped by the movement
fought for black studies
departments, the development
of afrocentric curricula and
various educational endeavors,
representation on the boards
of directors in organizations
serving black communities,
and greater racial diversity
and sensitivity in
organizations of all sorts.
And this element of Black Power,
the work that African-Americans
did within all sorts
of organizations
to bring the ideas of
the movement into them
is a process that's
less understood.
But it is one that, I think,
is essential to understanding
not only how these
institutions changed
over time, but also
the resistance even
by liberal whites
to those changes.
As the black struggle
shifted from calls
for color-blind, neutral
equality of opportunity
to color-conscious calls for
equality of condition delivered
in the urgent tone
of Black Power,
white resistance
also shifted, mostly
by using color-blind
rhetoric and policy
in ways that maintain
and continues
to maintain white supremacy.
Before I close, I want
to talk just a little bit
about my new project,
Black Power Lawyers.
But because I'm still
working through the data,
I'll talk just a little
bit about the framework
and my research process so far.
It's still early,
but I don't want
to miss the opportunity
to hear your feedback
and questions at this point.
So my new project is about
the National Conference
of Black Lawyers--
NCBL-- a group
that formed in 1968
with the express goal
to be the legal wing
of the revolution.
I came across this
organization when
I was doing work on
my last book looking
for black professional
associations, that big list you
saw up there.
And my interest was piqued.
And when I looked
further, I realized
that they were explicitly
tied to Black Power.
And I was immediately
curious about them,
because I had never
thought about Black Power
as having a legal wing
or a legal strategy.
But as I thought more
about the extreme state
repression of the movement
and the court cases that
resulted from it, it was
clear that the movement
had to engage with the
law and with the courts.
And so I found that
the papers of NCBL
are housed at Howard University.
Several other archives have
manuscript collections related
to Black Power era legal
cases-- the [INAUDIBLE]
holds the Angela Davis defense
collection, for example.
And many NCBL
attorneys have papers
collected in repositories
across the country.
So I visited most of them
and started the process
of collecting oral
histories with attorneys
who were active in this
organization in the period
that I'm interested in.
So as a whole, the book
will make the argument
that the Black Power movement
had a legal wing, which
is a sort of necessary
empirical argument,
given the way that we
think about Black Power
so far, that there's such
a thing as Black Power law
and lawyers who practiced it.
The book spans the
period from 1968 to 1977
and includes, for
example, elements
of the defense of Angela Davis,
Assata Shakur, Joan Little,
and the Attica brothers.
I end my time period
with NCBL's involvement
in the Bakke affirmative
action case in 1977.
I look at career effects of
defending unpopular clients,
the organization's global
advocacy, and their work
on behalf of black law students
and in defense of black lawyers
who found themselves facing
disciplinary charges.
So the piece that I'm working
on right now and sort of
in the mix of trying
to figure out I'm
calling Kangaroo
Court-- the courtroom
as a space of resistance.
In 1977, Lennox
Hinds, who was then
Director of the National
Congress of Black
Lawyers and Rutgers
criminal justice professor,
held a press conference
while court was in session
for the trial of Assata Shakur.
In it, he characterized the
trial as a legalized lynching
by a kangaroo court.
For his remarks, he was charged
with violating Middlesex Ethics
Committee Rule
7107d, which, quote,
"restricts the
speech of attorneys
who are associated with
pending criminal litigation
by sanctioning
attorneys from making
any extrajudicial statement that
they expect to be disseminated
to the public and that is
reasonably likely to interfere
with a fair trial."
In the end arguing that he
was not the attorney of record
and that the rule unfairly
restricted his First Amendment
rights, Hinds succeeded in
having the charges dropped
and actually brought
a suit of his own
against the ethics committee.
But his statements
are representative
of a genre of black
movement politics
that has yet to be given
much scholarly attention.
And that's courtroom resistance.
What I'm finding is that
the National Conference
of Black Lawyers' attorneys
and oftentimes their clients
conceived of the
courtroom as a space
for carrying out this
movement from pushing
the boundaries of what was
acceptable speech about court
cases, as in the Hines case I
just told you about, to using
strategic disrespect of trial
judges as a resistance tactic
to making incredible advances
in the use of social science
in jury selection.
NCBL attorneys used their
position as attorneys
in the service of Black Power.
So I want to just
conclude with this.
So there is no doubt that the
Black Power movement still
inspires young people.
And it's not just Beyonce at
the Super Bowl or Kendrick Lamar
at the Grammys.
The Black Lives Matter movement
and the new Black Student
Movement is all
raised fists, Assata
taught me, and by
any means necessary,
even in the face of white tears.
And the resistance
that the movement faces
is quite predictable when you
understand the racial dynamics
of color-blind racism.
I'm still wrapping my head
around these connections,
but they are quite
striking, really.
So for me as a student
of social movements,
it's not so much about
whether Black Power
has a lasting legacy, but
about how and to what end.
And my work tries to deal
with these questions.
But beyond this, knowing
that so many black people see
2016 as so similar
to 1966 should raise
many more curiosities
and, quite frankly,
should give us all pause.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]